the times are changing far faster than
the ever wore before and that requires a
new kind of thinking elastic thinking
fortunately there are ways you can
develop your elastic thinking there's a
ton of them here are five I call this
the idea of the day every day pick an
idea that you don't believe in try to
convince yourself that it's true I don't
mean just go through the motions I mean
sincerely try to imagine how somebody
who believes differently than you but
someone who you respect could accept
this idea and try to convince yourself
of it when we're wrong we often try to
forget it well this exercise is dwell on
when you were wrong remember a time when
you were wrong and the wrong or you are
and the more important it was the better
and think about it hard realize that
you're not always right one of the
barriers to elastic thinking is our
tendency to always think that we're
correct and to keep moving in the same
direction this exercise will help for
you of that
food this is a fun one go to a
restaurant that you pick at random or to
a restaurant that you normally wouldn't
go to and try something you normally
wouldn't order don't order the most
popular dish ask for the least popular
dish research shows that if you stretch
yourself in a way as simple as that it
helps increase your creativity and
imagination your parents taught you
don't talk to strangers well number four
is do talk to strangers in fact talk to
people is different from you as possible
people who believe what's different just
random people and try to understand how
they think and the more you're exposed
to what other people think the broader
your own thinking will be
[Music]
go see some art I don't mean a Rembrandt
I mean art that's different even if you
don't like it go see a damien hirst
exhibit because exposing yourself to art
that's different from the kind of art
you normally see will help you think
differently research shows that if you
do exercises such as these five things
you'll broaden your thinking you have an
easier time adapting to change you might
even be the one to create the change
yourself